[Music]
I think many much of my raffle
information previous talk so I will
forego that and just take the
opportunity actually to thank him for
his efforts here at MIT the last several
months
John has come here with some perhaps
delusions of taking a little bit easy
for a few months and instead of actually
a terrific job intersecting with
inviting students in particular to did
certain things in physics he has taken
initiative in holding pretty much time
discussions with the order team so black
students discussing all kinds of options
which students might pursue and their
physics and John didn't even carried
away and wanted to be a crystal resume
reviewer for each and every student oops
so the invitation
- so giant has wonderful impact in terms
of international students and I think
that's all I will say and to him his
talk today thank you very much I did in
fact make that offer I could not write
resumes I want to begin by sitting again
pleased I have to be the content
lecturer and how grateful I am to many
here at the audience in Timonium
Institute for your hospitality
and for very stimulating with
discoveries and interactions now my
first lecture some weeks ago was
entitled is basic research a luxury our
society can no longer afford some of you
may have heard a the answer that I gave
at that time was no basic research is
not a luxury it is a source of
competitive advantage but that answer
took 45 minutes to give and was quite
strongly qualified as
you may recall I argued that leadership
in basic research was neither necessary
nor sufficient for a nation to achieve
its economic and other goals the reason
for that being simply that successful
R&D is only about 5% of the job of
turning new knowledge into economic
value and societal family and then
countries that do much are all of that
other 95% in a world-class way can
achieve their goals without being
leaders in scientific research but I
went on to assert and I firmly believe
that the nation which does that 95
percent of the other 25% so to speak of
the job competitive way and is a leader
in basic research such a nation will
enjoy the competitive advantage in the
economic struggles that we are all going
to be pardoned of over the next decades
and since the United States currently
enjoys leadership and basic research I
argued it would be foolish for us to do
anything to forego that advantage while
we are at the same time addressing the
deficiencies in our national performance
on that other lady by the percent of
wealth creation which is not the search
of development and it is in thinking
about that other 95 percent of the job
and the roles that song
like play that I led to ask the question
of today's lecture what is a science PhD
for other than my early career as a
working scientist my question my
qualifications for asking this question
are only those of an employer and
manager of science for many years and an
observer of both the great strengths and
some of the weaknesses that scientists
bring with them when they venture away
from the university but as you know I
have no experience as a university
professor or administrator and so I'm
sure there are many aspects of this
problem which I'm ignorant English I
will miss here today I hope to convince
you and others outside University that
there is a need to assess the strengths
and weaknesses of the current
apprenticeship system of PhD training in
science and to look at the uses both
traditional and non-traditional to which
if I'm going to put that glass is PhD is
put need to look at those uses when
we're thinking about how the system
might be improved
my hope is really only that these
lectures will stimulate discussion will
help us with my discussion of all the
stakeholders including academics
scientists in private institutions that
employ scientists and in the funding
agencies that discussion needs to go
beyond the difficult and immediate and
pressing issues allow overhead costs the
size of the National Science Foundation
budget the budgets of some of the
science budget
the mission agencies those are urgent
matters but we need as I say also to
think about the role which scientists
will need to play in the coming decades
and what part of the funding agencies
and their future employers should play
in that process of course I'm well aware
that most of the analysis and the
suggestions for change if any must come
from those of us closely involved mainly
the university it's widely acknowledged
that with the end of the Cold War and
the escalation of international economic
competition the rationale for funding
non health related science and the
universities has changed and it's
beginning to be understood I think that
this implies increased attention in the
university to basic and applied research
in the so calls for teaching areas of
science areas which are of the net to be
helpful in achieving national goals part
of the difficulty of this whole subject
and we discussed it at the first lecture
is that there is widespread and I think
justifiable nervousness about how to
balance the vigorous pursuit of
strategic basic and applied research
with the appropriately vigorous support
of research in areas that I called
discipline totally true in a lecture and
UC Santa Barbara about two years ago
which was entitled research and
competitiveness problems of a new
rationale I pointed to many dangers for
research university
if they jumped without the character
thought onto the research for
competitiveness bandwagon I will to
discuss one major danger in that talk
namely the danger that science faculties
would try to adjust to the new
environment without asking whether
change is needed in the nature of PhD
training for some or all expenses so
that is the main topic of my remarks
today many of you know I'm sure that
other branches of dr3 of educational for
re-examining the training that they
promote for example medical education is
being rethought from the ground up the
example of that is the new pathway
program at the heart of interest so I've
already suggested I don't know how much
the topics I'm going to discuss today
are welcome to PhD training in the
biological sciences the rationale for
support research in the biological
sciences has not changed in the way that
it has changed for physics material
science mathematics in some parts of
chemistry I hope however that the
leaders in those fields are alert to the
possibility of the changes in in our
areas of science so to speak as far as
policy may spillover effect now I'm
going to give a brief characterization
of PhD training in science some of you
may feel a caricature conversation I
better tell you which we all know
already and what many viewers around are
right in the middle but a description of
the present system is necessary for
analysis I hope to reach people with
this discussion beyond the university
PhD training in the sciences as you all
know is best described as apprenticeship
guided students attach themselves early
and tightly to individual professors
indeed the attachment is some type in
many cases that the students identified
more strongly with the research group of
the professor than they do with the
department or even the University of
which there are many
despite mechanisms for ensuring common
standards I think it's fair to say that
the nature of an apprenticeship depends
strongly on the personality on the
intellectual spiral individual
professors here's the key relates that
in different groups often have very
different overall experiences and have
to leave
de facto different standards but this is
a tall would expect of apprenticeship as
opposed to qualification by standardized
testing or certification and I believe
the system has served as map in part
because of the flexibility that I've
just described indeed some of the
suggestions I had will increase one
increase the flexibility from the
students perspective in addition many
aspects of the present system of
training the sciences are strongly
influenced in ways that you'll
understand better than I do by the way
money flows from funding sources to
participants to the students to the
faculty to the university as a whole but
despite the continued existence of some
graduate fellowships for example in
which money flows directly to the
student most apprentice side scientists
are funded as you well know on a
research contracts and grants to their
professor this system involves to its
present
or during the Cold War in an atmosphere
in which the long-term trend was ever
increasing budgets and ever increasing
numbers of positions I repeat that the
system has served as well but I believe
it's time to take a fresh look at it now
I'd like to mention just briefly what I
believe are some of the principal
strengths training it for science at the
PhD level now what I'm about to say will
be obvious to those of you who are
faculty members but I know from recent
talks with graduate students that what
I'm about to say is not well understood
by some of them perhaps at that stage
Kennedy but it is my firm belief that in
addition to and more important than the
highly specialized scientific knowledge
that they obtain the PhD graduates
acquire a powerful methodology for
tackling technical problems starting
from an understanding and he drives to
understand the fundamentals of the
silver they learn how to pose a problem
how to decide what data where
experiments are required to solve and
obtain that data analyze it critically
and then this
spend their conclusions because they
learn how to learn new skills including
the ability to understand and use just
about every one of applied mathematics
to be sure the PhD student has the
experience in at least one area of guns
research volunteer coming back with some
new insight or any knowledge but the
scientific results thesis worked like a
large fraction of all published research
is of trends and is often of transient
family the true and lasting that of PhD
training is to have learned not an
answer but a process that reliably leads
the answers these are the main strengths
the scientific training at the graduate
level and their strengths whether one
uses them in a lifetime of further
scientific research or in a lifetime of
diverse work and service in any of a
host of non research science related
occupations incidentally it would be
foolish to reply that it's only PhDs in
science whose training provides them
with this intellectual armament error
many forms of engineering that they're
suited to the PhD level confer similar
medals but this is true principally I
think because in recent decades the
engineering curriculum has moved
struggling for engineering science as
its basis
that is certainly not a novel remark but
hasn't believed both some novelty and
urgency is asking whether the training
and the culture and I use the term
culture advisedly acquired by PhDs in
science can be improved to deal with the
challenges and opportunities that we
Esaias and we as citizens will face in
the coming decades my belief is that my
belief that it is appropriate to do this
reassessment may be strengthened or at
least it is strengthened in my mind by
taking a look not only at the strengths
which we just discussed but at some of
the weaknesses of the present system
with PhD training and weaknesses which
sometimes officiate the strikes we just
a spot now I have to say here and of
course I have only one respect but I
will tell you a number of things which
come how is that respect it's no novelty
to say to observe that new PhDs are
typically very narrowly specialized in
an area of their thesis reserved
indeed that others would be otherwise in
the current state of science and the way
the funds part award however
understandable this specialization maybe
it has unfortunate consequences in my
experience for the new Sciences view of
himself or herself sometimes this over
specialization and results both in a
lack of perspective which
understandable perhaps and a lack of
self-confidence as a science do magnets
often believed themselves ill-equipped
to venture outside the specialty area to
use their wonderful and powerful
training in jobs for example in R&D or
manufacturing or technical manager this
burden of over specialization is
compounded by was often a total lack of
work experience during the graduate
student years outside the university and
quite a culture which also suggested to
them not so subtle ways that becoming
like their professor should be the main
goal and work worse I would say the
culture of graduate training in science
or at least in some of the sciences
often suddenly imparts an intellectual
pecking order to the students view it is
a it is a view to the effect that
physics is better than campus viewers
better than apply that's for sure
this experiment chemistry both are
better than engineering and the
discipline and the intellectual content
for example are never considered at all
we need to try to make Western
civilization once and for all that
cultural violence if well for two
reasons first of all it has nothing to
do with nature nature doesn't understand
those distinctions nor respect secondly
those distinctions and the attitudes
that come with it often interfere or
mightily with young scientists having as
successful and exciting careers as they
might otherwise have now I'm aware that
many of these difficulties are
exacerbated for universities in what is
it concept and unintended consequence
perhaps the dark side if you will of the
peer-review system which is so important
for ensuring the quality scientific
funding distribution the dark side of
that system is the pressure to go ever
more deeply and expertly into a narrow
field where research results can be
quote guaranteed that that atmosphere
for cycles are real a real sense of
intellectual adventure the notion of
guaranteed results from research is
obviously an oxymoron but there is a
great tendency of peer review panelists
to travel to packs
and that behavior stifles risk-taking by
faculty and it's a lesson that is not
lost on graduate students now having
laid out is so briefly the strengths
which I believe are really formidable
and the weaknesses which I believe can
be dealt with with this apprenticeship
system the next part of the discussion
is really to talk a little bit about the
uses the traditional
additional uses to which science PhD
supplies as this audience certainly
knows the PhD degree is necessary but
not sufficient for becoming the member
of the science faculty the research
university it's necessary for becoming
the professor in almost all gone
research universities and many four-year
colleges and it's closely becoming a
necessary qualification for membership
on the research and development staff of
many governmental and private
laboratories now what are the and it is
it is those uses of course - for which
the apprenticeship program has been
designed and evolved over the years now
are the non-traditional uses to which
PhDs in science report the list will be
familiar to you as well but it is
central to my argument that each
non-traditional uses will be
increasingly important in ensuring that
society gets a timely and satisfactory
return on its investment in scientific
circles in many fields as you know the
large fraction of the phd's do not go on
to a career either the surgeon or an
academia or in government lands I think
petitions at number is almost 90% indeed
many dogs get into technical work at
industry outside their area of expertise
and training and so it's not common and
some of us Luca so development young
condensed matter experimentalists who
are working in a medical research firm
you will have colleagues of similar
cases many PhDs in science will of
course go on to become involved in the
management of the pliable surface
engineering and even manufacturing
programs in industry whereas I have
repeatedly seen this is something you
need to understand PhDs in science can
often compete successfully with
engineers including those with
engineering science PhDs and in
observing that I'm not simply calling
for scientists be trained like engineers
I'm just pointing out the deep breath
and the power of the science PhD in
training
in these positions PhD scientists are
often very well placed to help improve
the efficiency of the processes by which
new technical knowledge is turned into
economic or other value to society the
society which one was graduated training
and scientific research and which
expects those returns as its primary
result from the social contact of
support insulins now the addition of
holders of science PhDs participate
strongly in the management
state agencies which fund science
service technical staff in Congress and
other government awarding and in many
other places and in addition to those
who teach at the college level there are
many increasingly many who will teach
mindful of the college level or
otherwise be involved in the
interpretation of science to the public
by the way the science PhDs increasingly
use their quantitative modeling and
analytical skills outside science
altogether as The Economist magazine
pointed out a few weeks ago there is a
regular Spanish work though and here's
the point the short the PhD in science
would for many purposes be thought of as
a technical generalists degree although
these non-traditional uses have been
cleared for a long time their importance
to society and society support for
scientific research requires that they
be taken into account in new weathers
and as I said the reason is that 95
percent of the job which is not Rd the
job mileage new technical knowledge gets
burned into society and economic balance
the other leg climbers on the job has to
be done in a world-class wet and a
competitive activity a world-class kind
of way in the society that pays for the
research
is to be the society that gets a fair
return yeah it's clear that that 95
percent will just not are indeed now
involves many people with skills outside
of science to be sure but even so there
is much of that 99% of the job that can
and should be done by people with side
to the print I say can be done because
what does that work requires technical
understanding and I say should be done
because societies which do bring highly
trained technical generalists to bear on
this work may well have a comparative
advantage over in the economic content
of competition that overs countries who
smite us it's plagued Lester prominent
roles outside the line now here's an
important point of the Martin
presumption I think has been until now
that an educational process the
apprenticeship which was designed and
works well for the traditional uses of
the science PhD would do well we're
doing as well as needs to be done and
perhaps because as well as could be done
in fitting graduates for employment
science PhDs and what I call the
novelist
now I've already stated and I firmly
believe that the traditional training is
not bad preparation the fact it is quite
good preparation in some cases for these
non-traditional roles the question is
can it be done better and our other
societies doing that we're going to
learn indeed I believe that society they
welcome points at a moment between
developing and enlarged expectation of
what scientists can do on the one hand
and concluding that we have been largely
overrated in our contributions to
society on the other if this perception
is correct
it takes us it behooves us to take
improvement of graduate education very
seriously indeed
moreover Atlantic say-so as a
non-academic and as the visitors to this
but also to other universities as
students deserve better than the present
system tends to give they are often and
there are over 30 years old in many
cases before receiving the PhD or
completing the increasingly common two
to four years postdoctoral positions
only then in most cases do they get to
try the abundance in the world outside
academia a world of which many are
bigger in large measure because they
have never been neither been encouraged
nor allowed to spend time outside during
their study the human cost the
inefficiency the disappointment which
often occur it seems to me or no
defense nor is it any longer acceptable
that graduating students in the sciences
have so at often so narrower view of
their own scope for successful careers
well one of the most important lessons I
learned early on was that it's easier to
ask questions led to the answer but I
will share with you some thoughts about
where improvements played today in the
overall effectiveness of science PhD
dreamers
my first comment is that radical change
is not required train my apprenticeship
training by doom under the direction of
a more senior and experienced expert
really does work if the method were not
available to us we would Hales invention
as the major breakthroughs the changes
that they need to be made will lead the
system still perfectly capable of
producing new generations of researchers
and a new high degrees of the
professor's to the extent that proposed
changes are perceived as drawbacks or
faculty or for funding agencies I would
argue that the overall game to students
and to society when compensated for
those so I had five suggestions and I
really offer these in the full knowledge
that I am not really an expert my first
suggestion is that this whole area it's
called talking for reassessment of
graduate training be discussed and
debated widely there is already
widespread discussion of the rationale
for the goals and the means by which one
enjoy a return on the national
investment in silence an examination of
the training of science PhDs ought to be
part of that discussion and that should
take place in departmental and
university-wide groups and professional
societies in Brooklyn at the national
research council the national academies
and in funding agencies and in the hardy
enterprises
my second suggestion is that one welcome
this type of the realization that a
science PhD is in fact a technical
generalist degree in addition to being
the threshold for research and
university teaching faculties should
then begin to work out the consequences
of such an explicitly enhanced view my
third suggestion is that after
discussion with the funding agencies we
should try to ensure and I believe
ensure in the national interest that the
proportion of students supported by
fellowships be improved the aim should
be that it progressively largely larger
fraction of them who are supported in
their first one or two years by direct
fellowships rather than by support for
contracts attention to individual
research professors departmental
internships of the kind that are funded
by NIH would also come here by the way
the making is suggestion and I'm fully
aware of the fact that it goes counter
to the trends of the last 20 years
however in my view those trends are no
longer than
now if publicists were more widely the
source of our student support he would
begin to introduce a degree of
flexibility which would have several
beneficial effects first it would hardly
do negate the pressure to join a
research group in the first year of
graduate school and must start
specializing before one has really had a
chance to do the right amount of monthly
rent fellowship support for the first
two years will also make it possible for
students to spend at least one perhaps
two summers away from the University in
work settings which could help you norms
to give them the needed perspective
experience self-confidence and context
I trust students to have a reasonable
sense of what is in their own interest
and I would give them more flexibility
than the present system does I believe
most of them use it in ways that would
help to mitigate the effects of over
specialization
moreover fellowship support that is
increasing function support might
introduce new forms of competition
between the science departments of
research universities just as as it is
now the case that word gets to it's
around above young women as to which
schools and departments have made the
most effective efforts to deal with a
special product of women in science with
the result that some departments are
much more successful than others in
recruiting women
graduate students so word could get
around as to which math or physics or
chemistry or the thorough snacks
departments are best informed about and
most usefully coupled to the
non-academic world of scientific
employment to go with this increased
flexibility that would come with more
publishers support it might be useful
for graduate curriculum to include
possible suggested tailorable tracks
tailorable to the needs of students who
envision careers outside the research
university it might offer a way to
broaden one's preparation for example
for college teaching or for a career in
the government service or a career in
the technical sector of industry some of
the risks of the undergraduate at
masters level are experimenting with
programs in interdisciplinary areas such
as an environment and designing degree
programs which consciously tried to
provide my usual breath without undue
loss of debt
now maybe objective that such
possibilities are open to PhD students
now my reply is yes they are but there
isn't a lot of encouragement to take
them in most universities by the way I
am NOT I thank you to believe I have not
lecturing at MIT training when I have
some familiarity with a number of other
research universities in my cube well
assuming they may also be objected that
such a combination of different tracks
is not required in the best research
universities since their graduates are
all going to be real scientists and
these other options and possibilities
are appropriate perhaps for less public
schools and departments well in my view
the leading science departments should
aspire to train not only more than their
fair share the best researchers but also
more than their fair share of the
leaders in science and science related
fields my suggestion is that their
employer by the university reputation
it's no longer the case if it ever was
that there are no scientists and others
outside the University who are capable
of helping in some way to supervise PhD
theses moreover the efficiencies of such
shared supervision who will almost
certainly be more than offset by benefit
to all concerned students faculty
industrial colleagues and democracy now
of course not all internships
time spent away in summer or a semester
or whatever not all time spent away by a
long job would be suitable for thesis
and thesis work but some would in
thinking about this it has birth
debating that substantial intern type
experience during graduate school may be
one of the best indeed one of the very
few ways in which to effectively count
begins on over specialization that our
force
by the progress in science and by the
competitive culture of research and the
practices of peer review and the funding
process I think one Minister planted one
took this at all seriously once you
began to plan to begin offering this
option of external internships in a
small way first it takes time to build a
country of outside organizations of
individuals who will be able and willing
to provide meaningful internships one
sitting what one should plan to involve
people for most organizations in the in
the creation of such programs in the
first place and make sure that some of
them have a sense of ownership and
personal commitment local band or small
businesses are natural places to start
since the perception of mutual benefit
is likely to be large on the part of
small organizations for example because
they will be very sensitive you would
also have to expect that the willingness
outside of organisations to take on
graduate students as generalists rather
than a specialist will depend on many
factors that vary by company by industry
if an organization is expanding it will
be easy students with the generalist
partner if the organization is declining
but in general I think small small
organization startups and local
companies are easier to practice in this
regard you know I also think that it's
worth working on both from the
university side and National Lab or
private industry side work on minimizing
the financial and bureaucratic barriers
for faculty members to enter into true
partnerships with colleges since these
genuine partnerships are often excellent
vehicles for providing non-university
experience for graduate students and
indeed there are many good examples of
such partnerships that I know about here
in science and MIT my definite final
suggestion has to do with opportunities
for selects faculty members themselves
there's so far been discussing and
options for
broaden the perspective and experience
of students but there is value as well
to providing opportunities for faculty
to broaden their knowledge of the ways
in which Sciences of the work in the
world outside of the university so I
believe the university funding agencies
and private industry national labs
should all consider nothing to provide
fellowships Consulting sabbaticals and
other incentives and meals to enable
professors definitely choose to spend
time away from the university in
non-academic settings worse
by the way to do the doneness one aspect
of that very well
university professors well understand
their obligation to take a turn for
example as rotators of the National
Science well to summarize my
recommendations and then leave some kind
of for discovery I suggested first that
reexamination of PhD training science
would be part of the discussion agenda
of the many groups of have a state in
science PhDs second that fellowships
support be used increasingly to help
mitigate some of the problems of too
early specialization third that serious
thoughts be given to have it brought
into perspective huggable and
experienced advantage students through
optional but strongly encouraged
technical internships outside nineteen
fourth things and anonymous
opportunities be created and be
considered normal for faculty and forth
I had a late lunch Bronwyn for this but
invited rather that foundations and
other non governmental sources of funds
look hard once again and whether they
cannot that that margins at least lift
some of the enormous pressure for
scientific informing now let me repeat
that I do not expect to have come up
with the best ideas or necessarily a lot
of good ideas for improving brighter the
trend that can only be done by those of
you
more deeply involved if I have observed
that these changes by themselves will
not relieve many of the other major
stresses on the research university
system and they're not suggesting to
that one they are suggested simply with
the idea that they might improve the
careers and the social utility of
fugitive science PhDs and buy some GUI
striking the research university and our
national commitment to excellence thank
you very much for your attention I would
be happy to entertain
[Applause]
[Music]
well the problem which shows with just
raised how is that one convinces in the
first place many that is not everyone in
industry is as convinced as I am about
the value of a PhD if indeed many of
their fellows that I am but there is a
serious dilemma here and the students I
met with
disgusting what there is a tendency to
wonder for people based on their
specialness and if you don't happen to
be looking for a specialty or if it
doesn't have to be in demand this year
that really complicates life I think
there are that part of the job mainly
falls on the outside of organizations
and it's one of the reasons why I'm
addressing these remarks and some some
subsequent article to those well I think
it is in fact possible to make progress
there and as I said it's easy to
reference it's different for different
but there are some problems you've
addressed the problem
[Music]
especially is there given some guidance
that's why I had the suggestion about
the I spent a year away from between
college and graduate school I spent a
year traveling in Europe was obviously
it was easily the best investment of
time I ever made and now he spent six
summers in university research so first
of all there is there is no no fog in my
mind that people would be required to go
back and work where they in terms of
course they would have contacts that
would make it easier for them to do so
or to visualize the question of
citizenship is one when I'm sure Bob or
Dave
for good investors to coalesce their
hooves it to sort of professor group
research
I wonder if from the perspective of your
talk you felt that a single you know one
professor one group or pressure tendency
depending again on the members of the
group to prevent the professorial
members in the group it could could have
some very beneficial consequences I
suppose given that there would be a
wider range of experience background of
the contacts is wrong but I don't think
that would be a fundamental or
necessarily detrimental change to the
system
can you hear the question because
although I moved it to HP's in
engineering when I changed my analysis
if I were talking to primarily engineers
of course there are some in the audience
I think the only way the only I have
talked about some these ideas with the
engineering council if I may say so I
think the engineering faculty I think
generally the engineering faculties are
further down this road
I address that I bought my first
recommendation remember was that this
whole topic needs to be vigorously and
openly discussed and I can't an outsider
I can't do more than and say that if it
were and if it were also discussed the
you know in first national levels I
believe a ways would be found to
harmonize these interests I don't think
you know I came across in this lecture
to demonize to have a very interesting
thesis which is that PhD and I would say
in engineering as well as in science can
serve as a basis for a career outside of
science or engineering in modern society
which is so technologically based it
gives a person a lot of skill and it
seems to me that that aspect might be
obtainable some of us only a bachelor's
in science or engineering and then the
question is what is the added value of
the PhD and I heard you saved the
ability to formulate problems to have
come in the methodological way and so on
is it isn't all that great than anything
at all my question is that is that a
vitally work that in some sense for
someone who does not aspire to work
within the system of science or
technology well I would observe
I've thought a lot about those questions
and
I have many colleagues in senior
management at IBM who were very
effective technical managers whose only
normal training was the Esper's
so I did not mean to suggest that one
can only get this power that this
approach to problems by the science
teacher however I believe that the
experience of doing that apprenticeship
does in fact confirm extra skills or if
it adds to the weight of the artillery
that can be brought there I also think
that the the fact I was arguing also to
sort of face what I think is the reality
that most that a very large fraction of
people who start and who genuinely
enjoyed research in the starter research
career will end up doing other things I
mean I I did not them I did not go
through graduate school with the notion
you know ending up managing a plant in
East Michigan or the laboratory's
fishery but the various aspects of my
own case in which I was fortunate to
have this wide range of experience that
led me to believe that the very large
fraction of research scientists who will
end up doing other things sooner or
later in their career
importantly would be better at those
jobs and would for example find their
way to them more easily and more quickly
if they had the wide-ranging experience
on fun but it's a it's a subtle argument
and it's um it's clearly debatable
on the other hand I think I think the
view that PhD training is just for
people who want to spend away in
research I really believe in today's
world that's a bonus or at least unless
one is willing to see the whole
enterprise run by factors you suggested
that there would be a project that might
be done in a user environment during
one's PhD training I guess my concern is
how would you structure that project so
that it would be a valuable experience
as it is it seems that it's somewhat hit
or miss finding a good project that's
the length scale for a PhD and certainly
my experience of doing a undergraduate
project which was six months or eight
months is that it's much more hit or
miss but you can do something that you
can learn from and still make a
contribution to how would that work I
think first of all that's why I
suggested when I start small
secondly it's something that a lot of
effort has to go into but I don't
professor Castro move about cases where
that has worked out very well and others
so I think it's a question of raising
the sense of priority and attention that
we devote to
a very common concern my own experience
it is and I see in my own experience
that I may be peculiar this regard it
was a it was the easiest difficulty to
be overcome for example if something is
is packable that is no patent comes out
of the work better get on somebody
better get on the stick and file back
before the pieces is due or before the
publication is to be published
well last time at the first lecture
remember I said that the seminars that
the Rd world is really 10 or 20 times
bigger than the part that I served
to the world of science and worse so
there is a small part of work and
industry that would lend itself to
thesis work but still it's a substantial
part in absolute terms of substantial
now I did not make clear and I do want
to make clear that I don't think that
these internships have to be thesis
related I think that's asking too much
there aren't that many opportunities
many of the benefits see well how
science was done their technology is
done out there they have benefits the
contacts the perspective would come from
doing work which was full of content but
we're just not necessarily the
publishers yeah that will interrupt if
one did it after year for obviously that
would be but I don't think it's possible
to have the way that lets a customer in
Japan they have 60% of all PhDs for work
done in industry that I'm not suggesting
that market
I'm not sure I understand the process I
did not I did not explore the question
how many PhD is the world long to have
there are people in the audience who
have been thinking about that I have
some thoughts you know that would be
another lecture but the fact is that as
I said it's just plain the fact that
many many PhDs end up working outside of
research moreover in a number of fields
that I know well for example computer
science in the industry the willingness
to the understanding of the value of pH
DS is increasing so was it in
development when I started at IBM 30
years ago it was almost unheard of that
any of our 40 development labs
Hydra phd's now it's routine we the
world does change people doing so I
think the answer is that we can do
better
with this or the size of the enterprise
that is not whether that enterprise will
or should shrink say it is a subject for
another another one
thank you very much
you